you know i guess what like what's the
[ __ ] meaning of life bro boy what
rosie bro you're gonna bring that out
man what is this [ __ ] trash chase
right now like why why what are we what
is what is our purpose man what are we
doing rick and morty is too deep to
understand rig
i don't know man it's just like oh you
know the same reason why when i look at
a i look at a fish what's the what's the
fish doing what's the fish's purpose
you know
what to get in my stomach right exactly
just be [ __ ] eaten by someone else
right yeah so
what you say he's sitting around being
like so what is the purpose of this so i
sit here and i look at like all these
animals that just there to be eaten or
to survive and i think that in some
senses we're just the same we're not
we're not we don't have some grand
purpose to have some spiritual
experience it's just we're just here to
[ __ ] eat and get on with our [ __ ]
life
if i want to play some goddamn league of
legends for 12 hours a day that the
universe has allowed me because i've
done my duty which is survive and now i
can mentally destroy my life be a league
but you know i think once you've done
once you've survived that's it i believe
i believe they call that a nihilist
the problem is is that now we just have
now now survival is just the rules have
changed man used to being a sigma male
man now it's hard are they gonna pay
bills [ __ ] man i gotta be sigma mail
while i pay the bills [ __ ] that single
mail don't pay your bills number one
sigma mail grinds bills pay you
yeah i don't know because that's you
know i i don't really believe there's a
lot of uh a lot of [ __ ] going on in life
i just kind of think that you just kind
of
just find that you get to get popped and
you just what you're doing that's fine
i i wish that i could have some more
enjoyment out of it
i would but that's just not how i feel i
don't know why that's fine man i wonder
what made me feel that way well how do
you guys feel about it is he comfortable
talking about it yeah yeah sure um yeah
i guess like i don't know for me it's
like at least with like the whole ghost
thing for me is like obviously i had
that story i told you guys about my
sister going through you feel like it
reflects your kind of spiritual
yeah i mean i i i believe more i have a
lot more um
respect for spirituality than i do
religion i think i organize religion i
agree
i agree
we're talking about this
we don't want to go too deeply
oh my god we're we're like take we're
taking on every topic that you shouldn't
be talking about right now
let's talk about right left
now for like for me personally it's like
again because i did grow up in uh
yeah i mean like yeah it was like the
whole shintoist belief and you know used
to go to temples all the time and you
know would hear stories about you know
my grandparents like being very you know
shintoist and just believing in again
like that whole spirituality and like
that like i like spirituality yeah yeah
yeah yeah i like something
you know i can get behind anything that
the general belief is be good and you
will get good yeah you know like
yeah you know being nice to people like
when i was a kid you know my grandma
would tell me like uh you know like
don't throw the rubbish in the river not
because it's bad for the pollution but
because the river god is going to get
angry at you and i'll come back to bite
you in the ass i'm like oh [ __ ] well i
don't want to anger them
i'll do that yeah right it might be a
little bit of an ass backwards logic but
you know as a kid like that is i think a
healthy way to like look at a logical
explanation get behind anything that is
generally just be a nice person yeah
exactly just give back yeah that's like
because i feel like i'm i want to do
that just myself i don't need some um
kind of
belief system for me to do that i just
want to be a good person and do that
because i want to give back i'm not
walking around as a 27 year old going oh
[ __ ] i better not anger this yeah
right but like at the back of my mind
there is a part where it's you know
it builds like not only respect for
surroundings around you but also just
becoming a better person and it's like
you do what you have to believe in as
long as you're not hurting anyone else
believe what you have to believe in to
be a better person no because uh like my
experience was you know obviously i was
raised up to be a buddhist and
everything like that in my life yeah i
mean okay so i was so his here's a bit
more behind that backstory right so i
was a monk when i was a kids yeah write
it down write it down
uh so as i said before you i was among
two times my life one time as a kid one
time as an adult uh so the kid thing was
basically doing it so i could like you
know give good karma to my family
because that's just how that's just how
i was great you know i was too gen z i
thought you're on about reddit then
finally enough karma was the concept
that existed before ready
[Applause]
um so so then i you know so then after
that i went to university grew up and
everything and then i had this i i had
this you know uh spiritual experience uh
with with uh
with with some people and then after
having that experience i kind of just
like
i don't know what the right word or the
right term to like coin this as but i
just kind of realized that i didn't know
what the [ __ ] i believed right yeah
right because because because i had this
experience that i couldn't explain
logically and i was like an engineer
before so i'm just like everything
scientifically
scientific everything can be explained
logically had this experience and then i
kind of realized
[ __ ] what do i believe right and then
then and then at that point i realized
everything that i believed wasn't
because i actually believed it but it
was just because that was what i was
raised to believe so yeah that's that's
one thing that's really difficult
because i mean you have to be raised
yeah yeah yeah yeah we can't
so it's kind of hard to get an unbiased
view of like a a
religion or a spirituality because you
often have so much like baggage or kind
of backstory with that kind of thing so
yeah it's often hard to look at it
critically yeah so like that that was
like actually a huge turning point in my
life that like basically put my clean uh
put me like put me on a clean slate and
i was like okay i'm going to become a
monk now and that was like that was like
the actual point when i'm like damn i'm
going to become a monk not because my
parents told me to but because i need to
like figure this [ __ ] out myself and
figure out
is this what i actually believe or is it
or is it something that was instilled to
me as a kid and so that was like that
was like the big decision maker to be
like i'm gonna start something new in my
life i'm going to like try to
experience this lifestyle not because
not because anyone told me to but
because i chose this i chose to
experience this and whatever comes out
of this experience and whatever comes
out of these beliefs are my own and
that's why right now i you know so i
became a monk when you were [ __ ]
alone by yourself with your thoughts for
four uh for four weeks or a month two
months uh you have a you have a lot of
time to think about [ __ ] right yeah and
so in these in these like two months you
be i basically just like had time to
rewind my entire life and basically
break down
why i believe the things i do and why
i'm the person i am yeah and
like after becoming a monk and after
having that time to myself and you know
studying you know i already knew about
you know buddhist the british religion
and the buddhist beliefs and the and so
i after that i knew what i believed out
of let's say what the traditional
religion teaches you yeah but i also had
my own beliefs and my own views on top
of that i think that's why it should be
though i think that's you should take
the cause of something you like a
structure that you and like a of a
spirit or whatever yeah you like and
then just kind of add your own like
things that you really want to i mean
japan is pretty notorious for that right
yeah religion and it's like yep this is
what we believe i don't know like the
whole thing with that karma as well like
i i i'm in like a scientific way i think
that if you know if if generally if
you're a good uh you know your positive
impact on on people i think just it just
comes back like yeah every reaction is
you know do i believe there's this
cosmic system well like like god's
keeping track
of someone's keeping dragging like oh
you're all naughty
i'd like to think so yeah
i mean i could just go and do whatever
the [ __ ] i wanted yeah
but do i believe in like in general if
you're a good person that it will come
back 100 yeah of course of course i
truly believe that and like
that's that i guess is the biggest thing
the biggest change before like before me
just being told what to believe and
actually like deciding what i believe
it's like once you decided it or once i
decided it nothing can change my opinion
because i was like i'm so like set in my
beliefs because this is basically
everything that i've built from my
entire experience of life and the only
thing that can change this is new things
i experience because like
because that and to me that's why i
guess
nothing really phases me when it comes
to like arguing about my beliefs like my
core beliefs because i'm sorry i'm very
set in it i don't i don't really feel
like i have anything controversial
either i just kind of like yeah man just
should be good i mean like you say like
you had all this whole experience but i
mean ultimately we came to the same
conclusion right through our own means
right i think that's what it's about i
don't know i i don't have a problem with
how however you want to do your life
just don't yeah don't be a negative
impact
again you're free to believe whatever
the [ __ ] you believe just don't like
hurt or inconvenience others yeah like
what pisses me off is when people try to
put their beliefs on other people like
yeah i have my core beliefs and i firmly
believe them but i would never try to
say hey this is my experience and you
should experience and believe exactly
the same thing as me
because because to me to me you can't
you can't force that on someone you know
you can you can raise a kid but i hope
my kid goes to the exact same thing that
i went through when they realized [ __ ] i
i need to like decide this [ __ ] for
myself yeah i'm sure there's a lot of
people watching this i've never thought
about this deeply and you know for
that's that's not exactly a bad thing
because
it's something that i never had to think
about until i had some experience that
forced me to like put myself put me in
this position to think about it there's
not there's no you can just go your
whole life and you've been you've been
raised to believe a certain thing yeah
and you just never questioned it yeah
that's what i always found quite like
odds because i was always questioning
everything from like the get-go like
anything they told me i was like no yeah
you know which is strange because i
i guess that's why i'm so adverse to
stuff like that because ever since a
young age i can remember i was the
annoying kid who was like no i don't i
don't think that's right
you know but that's just because i don't
know how i i don't know where i got that
mindset from but i've always been like
that
i guess just some people just don't
really question things because they just
think oh if i just follow what everyone
else believes and if i just follow the
crowd then nothing can go wrong right so
you're telling me i'm a sigma manager
some people just have never thought that
deeply about it and that's fine well
there's a lot of people i've met in your
life dude there's a lot of people i've
met who are just
[Applause]
honestly i wish i was more like that
because my god like some people out here
existential crisis in the bathtub yeah
yeah
meanwhile members of the church of the
flying spaghetti monster are like we're
[ __ ] happy dude we got there we got a
[ __ ] spaghetti monster on our side
yeah for me for me i just think just
don't try to put your beliefs on other
people try to accept what anyone else
believes even if it's like different
from yours you can believe what the [ __ ]
you want you could like if people want
to hear about your experiences and give
you that opportunity then go ahead tell
your experiences tell your beliefs but
if if if they're not interested which a
lot of people are not going to be
interested then just give them don't get
offended don't get offended and don't
get offended whether they believe
something different as well definitely
understood that whole aspect of it
getting really angry about other
people's
well like being like how dare you don't
believe the same thing i believe that
[ __ ] yeah i never got that either
it just seems very like i don't know
it's like you're very like like
self-concerned about like yeah weird
feeling
and [ __ ] like that it's like she's gonna
be able to be comfortable somewhere okay
yeah i guess uh if you have a
a dietary requirement yeah well it's not
a big deal
it's like one meal of my life that we
won't be able to eat pork like i think i
think i'll be all right like i'm not
offended yeah
it's fine i'm good
you know and even then it's like it's
you know it's uh it's it's kind of
strange i don't know
it's deep it's deep